i'm here at one of the areas that has
been flooded by the torrential rain in
the capital city of central china to
hernan province
where the rescue work is still underway
the heavy rainfall in a capital city
drunk draw has left
12 dead as of early wednesday and rain
has been suspended right now
by weather forecast say it will last
until tomorrow
latest from the local authorities say
that the rainfall in the capital city
reached 610 millimeters in the past
three days
while its whole year rainfall remains
around 640 millimeters
which means the city has witnessed this
whole year rainfall in just
three days the central theater people's
liberation army said
on wednesday morning that the it has
sent
more than 3 thousand men and 80 sets of
equipment to fight the floods
and carry out a rescue walk in the city
as its emergency response
level of flight has been raised to level
one
the railway operators have carried out
measures to ensure
safety such as stopping services and
lowering the operation speed and some
residential areas in the city
have been cut off water supply and
electricity
the provincial flight control and
drought relief headquarters reported
that more than
140 thousand residents have been
affected by torrential rains
in hunan since july 16 and 10 000
have been relocated safely so far